klassisch fortsetzung folgt
haltet euch sie plane keine andere
filmemacher das so dramatisch miserabel
wie ibm plant eine eigentliche
geschichte über eine außergewöhnliche
wir aber geführt es direkt in eine
katastrophe sherpas die wahren helden am
everest die dem film von sieben jahre
habe der junge chef nobuo kennengelernt
und auf uns vor dem jahren wiedertreffen
und erfahren dass er sich inzwischen
zieht eine schweizerin verliert dem
fröhlichen die beiden miteinander wähle
auf dem mount everest und aus dem grund
als teamfoto begleitet am 25 april aber
hat das schwere erdbeben erschüttert
der nabu sherpa und seine freundin sind
sie mitbringen plötzlich gott zu nehmen
und den gemeinsamen traum vom gipfel
sondern nur noch darum irgendwie können
wenn das entschieden die geschichte
nichts weiter als erzähler hat und am
nächsten kritik und auf eine firma mit
reis zurück und beschert
der mount everest mit 8848 die hilfe der
sherpas
sie tragen die lasten bereiten den
westlichen bergsteigern den weg einer
dieser sherpas ist norden 29-jährige am
anfang seiner karriere
für mich geht es nicht nur ums geld im
innersten meines herzens wollte ich
schon immer mal auf dem gipfel stehen
[Musik]
nobel sherpas zu hause ist kathmandu die
hektische hauptstadt nepals mit über 1,2
millionen einwohnern ist sie das zentrum
des landes
norbu wuchs bei einer tante rita
schilling indien auf wo er eine gute
ausbildung bekam in kathmandu von der
darauf einen job bei einer trekking
agentur die mit dem schweizer bergführer
kari kobler zusammenarbeitet zu beginn
arbeitete er hier im büro
später bekam er die chance auf
expeditionen mitzugehen
zunächst als küchenjunge doch dann
wurden seine qualitäten erkannt und er
wurde ein so genannter climbing sherpa
kleinen sherpas die in kathmandu haben
gute möglichkeiten geld zu verdienen und
sich eine bessere zukunft aufzubauen
norbu möchte nicht ein leben lang diesen
gefährlichen und anstrengenden job als
climbing sherpa ausüben sondern später
den ruhen das geld und seine kontakte
nutzen um sich weiter zu entwickeln
während der kurzen bergsteiger sommer
ist noch bus hauptquartier das
basislager am mount everest bei den
lohnverhandlungen mit expeditionsleiter
kari kobler ist nur bruder sprecher der
sherpas no go ist ein sogenanntes serie
dar einleiten der sherpa seine kollegen
fordern mehr grundlohn und auch mehr
geld für jedes kilo last dass sie in die
verschiedenen hochlager tragen ihr wollt
50 ich will 40 zahlen also sagen wir 45
alle sollen zufrieden sein
und ist man einigt sich die sherpas
verdienen auf dieser expedition 4500 bis
5.500 dollar je nach leistung
es ist das doppelte jahressalär eines
lehrers in kathmandu aber dafür müssen
sie leiden
sie schleppten jeder 25 kilo lasst den
schwierigen eisfall schon morgens um 5
kommt es dann zu ersten staus so viele
sherpas sind unterwegs
kann mir mal wieder
novo als junger kräftiger sherpa
versucht dem stau auszuweichen und
handelt sich nebenan an einem seil die
eiswand hoch je mehr die sherpas tragen
und je öfter sie rauf und runter steigen
desto besser verdienen sie eine fast
übermenschliche anstrengung sherpas sind
wirklich viel stärker als westler wir
sind von geburt weckern berge gebühren
das ist aber noch etwas treibt die leute
an als ihr da macht nobo im lager zwei
inventar des von den sherpas herauf
geschleppten materials es ist viel faule
säcke sauerstoff flaschen und zählte 50
sauerstoffflaschen benötigt die
expedition
sie müssen noch bis auf 7900 meter hoch
gebracht werden
[Musik]
eine weitere schwere aufgabe norbu
klettert mit einigen sherpas dieser
eiswand hoch um das lager 3 auf 7.300 m
einzurichten
die anstrengung in der immer dünner
werdenden luft ist groß der platz für
lager drei liegt an einem steilen hang
und die zelte aufzustellen müssen die
sherpas zuerst das eis auf hatten und
den boden ebnen
keine leichte sache auf dieser höhe aber
sie schaffen s ein paar tage später sind
alle vorbereitungen abgeschlossen
die westlichen bergsteiger machen sich
auf richtung gipfel und die sherpas
tragen das material der teilnehmer hoch
jeder buckelt hier um die 25 km und das
auf einer höhe zwischen 7300 und 7900
metern
es kommt zu staus
nur wo kommt nur mühsam voran auf 7800
meter machte eine kleine pause es ist
ein schwieriger job heute denn jeder von
uns trägt 25 26
die teilnehmer haben alles
zurückgelassen
sie tragen nur ihre unterhosen den
daumen anzug und einen kleinen rucksack
wir dürfen uns aber all diese
schwierigkeiten nicht anmerken lassen
wir müssen immer eine fröhliche miene
aufsetzen
da kann man nichts machen das ist die
natur dieses jobs nach über acht stunden
aufstieg wird norbu von
expeditionsleiter kari kobler im lager
vier begrüßt
bald legen sie sich schlafen denn schon
um 10 uhr nachts soll es weitergehen
es folgt der gipfelsturm
norbu ist der erste der aus dem zelt
kriegt
als du
bitte
bevor es losgeht kontrollieren die
sherpas die sauerstoffflaschen ihrer
gäste jeder sherpa betreut fortan einen
gast und trägt ihn auch die
sauerstoffflaschen nach nachdem sie die
ganze nacht gelaufen sind erreichen sie
um fünf uhr morgens den süd gipfel die
verhältnisse sind gut aber jeder schritt
schmerzt
auch lob der yuna starkes leidet
es folgt das letzte stück der hillary
step benannt nach dem erstbesteiger des
everest sir edmund hillary
und dann steht norbu zum ersten mal auf
dem dach der welt er hatte schon vier
mal versucht aber er musste jeweils bei
seinen kunden bleiben und umkehren
nun ist es vollbracht novo entfaltet
seine fahnen um den göttern zu danken
ich habe es in den letzten vier jahren
von norden und von süden ausprobiert
jetzt bin ich auf dem höchsten berg der
welt mit hilfe meiner verrückte meine
gebetsfahnen flattern im wind
ich fühle mich nahe bei gott ich bin
überglücklich ich werde diesen moment
nie vergessen
das gipfelglück dauert nur eine stunde
dann folgt der abstieg nur begleitet
seinen kunden sicher hinunter
vor sieben jahren haben der sherpa nabu
begleitet wo zum ersten mal ganz offen
ist somit auf den mount everest und hut
für fortsetzung folgt für kindermode
nabu wieder in den bergen aber und das
ist die große überraschung im himalaya
sondern da in die schweizer berge im
wallis im kleinen dorf bei rosa lyon
wurde japan abu dhabi schweiz brachte
und in einem husumer jetzt der nabu lebt
in den wintermonaten bis in ihre
freundin andrea zimmermann
hallo schön dich zu sehen schön euch zu
sehen war das ein großes team dabei
dürfen wir reinkommen
ja klar
das hätten wir nicht erwartet dich
sieben jahre nach dem film hier
anzutreffen
das letzte mal sahen wir dich auf dem
gipfel des everest hättest du dir
vorstellen können dass du eines tages in
der schweiz landes nein das hätte ich
nie gedacht
damals gab es für mich nur den everest
aber dann traf ich auf einer expedition
und her
ich besuchte sie 2012 zum ersten mal in
der schweiz und dachte was für einer nun
bin ich hier glücklich schön dich hier
zu sehen
ich bin sehr gespannt wie ihr
gemeinsames leben aussieht darüber reden
wir gleich am ort wo sie die freundin
andrea zimmermann welt den vorwurf bis
vor kurzem internationale
sportgerichtshof in lausanne geschaffen
die 83 jährige macht aber auch selber
leistungssport und zum beispiel oder
weltmeisterschaft im skitourenrennen
bergers inter andrea ihre ganz große
liebe schafft das verbindet sie mit dem
norden
[Musik]
verstehst du ein wenig schweizerdeutsch
nur ein paar wörter die ich auf
expeditionen aufgeschnappt haben was die
leute sagen wenn sie die berge sie
das sind so die wörter die ich kenne wie
und wo habt ihr euch genau getroffen
[Musik]
wir haben uns 2011 auf einer expedition
zum bergschuhe kennengelernt der
sechsthöchste berg der welt und andrea
war eine kundin von dir ja sie war einer
meiner kundinnen und so kam mir zusammen
perfekt
über den ort bin ja kein fernsehen
ja aber ich ganz lustig werden innerhalb
expedition bücher ja gar nicht also
weiter sorge macht denkt dass das mit
eure zukunft ja irgendwie schon aber
nachher ist praktisch wenn ich hier
woche für woche pro woche gloria hat das
bistum habe das ganze jahr bisher so mit
ruß machen
im taktischen gründen auf für trekking
und expeditionen jetzt bist du in nepal
sind wir ein wenig träge was das
arbeiten geht
wir sagen okay vielleicht in zehn
minuten
okay vielleicht in einer halben stunde
kommt auch morgen noch mal andrea läuft
es anders
los geht's fünf minuten zeit disparat zu
machen in zehn minuten gehen wir dahin
in 20 minuten sind er dort das sieht
ziemlich streng
du sagst andrea gibt den takt andrea
wird gut trainiere sg truman tag wo die
wahl der mit bussen unterwegs sind
egal wie wählen weiter mit wenn
skulpturen skifahrer norbert ski fahre
er stuft andreas land die hätte everest
bezwingen erste mal für das paar stunden
juli liegt mittlerweile mit 1 haben
überall aber als risikospiel norden
andrea hat ihr das skifahren beigebracht
wirst du sie dafür eines tages auf den
everest bringen
wir planen gemeinsam den everest zu
besteigen und zusätzlich noch einen
handeln achttausender eine spezielle
tour
also das ist ja
im tor ist andreas tempo vorgibt
die beiden schienen sich gut ergänzen
das geschäft der gott als joint venture
von schwyz und nepal und andrea ich
genau zuverlässig und keine sprüche oder
westliche kunden unter norbert vieler
vorhang mit ihm allein expeditionen
redet englisch und funktioniert als
sherpa anarchie oder meister roland luft
ausgeht
kein problem hier hoch zu laufen oder
manche leute denken war du kommst aus
dem himalaya
du hast sicher eine gute ausdauer und
kannst du einfach hoch rennen aber so
ist es nicht
denn wenn du ein yak in die sahara
stellst geht es ein oder ein kamel in
den himmel ein
er wird mein körper anders gefordert als
daheim das muss ich ausbalancieren
gleichgewicht findet norbu und andrea
wichtig zwischen den beiden kulturen aus
verbundenheit zu nepal herzstiftung
butterfly hält project aufgestellt zum
nepalesische kind unterstützen
es soll sich nicht alles nur um die
höhere berge dreier am schluss vom tag
kredit obersten führers funde in den
letzten sieben jahren die häufig wasser
auf dem gibt's vom everest
insgesamt war ich nun sechsmal auf dem
everest dreimal von der nepalesischen
und reimer von der tibetischen seite wo
warst du im letzten jahr im letzten jahr
war ich zum glück nicht auf expedition
denn es gab ja leider dieses große
unglück bei dem ich drei gute freunde
vor
das war sehr traurig
das letzte jahr war sehr aktiv und 20
sherpas von einer lawine mitgerissen
worden 16 sind gestorben
ein streik geht meist expeditionen
halbzeit werden was hast du gedacht hast
du gehört hast das 16 deiner kollegen
bei der arbeit gestorben sind
zu beginn war alles völlig unklar
wir wollten herausfinden wer die opfer
waren ich versuchte von kathmandu aus
das basecamp zu kontaktieren es war ein
großes durcheinander
am nächsten tag fuhren wir wer vermisst
wird und wir wussten dass es keine
hoffnung gibt dass diese 16 noch leben
was geschieht mit einer familie wenn sie
den vater ehemann und somit den arm er
am everest verliert jetzt müssen wir das
machen
hier setzt eure stiftung an deine
familie helfe wo otto von orient wo
verwandte verloren hat sich wirklich
dass man kinder bist jetzt also das ist
obligatorisch so dass man sie bis dahin
könnte banker und denn nach wie vor sei
als papier- und was denkst du was sind
die konsequenzen aus diesem
lawinenunglück für diese saison in
diesem jahr
die leute sind sehr verängstigt das
trauma ist noch da aber sie brauchen
auch das geld die bergsteiger werden
kommen und damit viel arbeit denn der
mount everest das dach der welt hat
diese große faszination ja offenbar
immer noch kritisch akw stehen große
traum
[Musik]
vom hc lugano wo wärst du sie
unterstützen
du weißt wie gefährlich der everest sein
kann und andrea ist die person die ihr
am wichtigsten ist
ich möchte sie in ihrem traum
unterstützen
es gibt risiken und gefahren da tun dazu
die höhe
aber ich bin sehr froh und weiß wie man
damit umgeht und du kennst andrea sehr
gut
ja ich kenne sie sehr gut manchmal sage
ich zu ihr du wirst keinen besseren
bergführer als ich mit dem was ich
glaube ja
[Musik]
zwei monaten auch unsere begegnung im
wallis in den augen und andrea auf nepal
kreist zu musste erst kurz meinte aber
auch um ihre strecken unternehmer für
schicks bringen
andrea ist erst mit hunden unterwegs und
macht sich darum allein richtig er ist
auf dem weg spürt oder schafft er vom
unglück vor vier jahren noch deutlich wo
16 sherpa freunde ums leben sind das ist
bis zu dem zeitpunkt die größte tragödie
am mount everest und auch nicht klar da
sie das nicht mehr passieren
preis von oben gefunkt in kathmandu a
täter suchte der segen für sie haben tür
und begleitet wird er von frank sein und
vom otto zenica
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für norbu beginnt jede expedition in
boppard einem vorort von kathmandu die
gläubigen buddhisten gehen hier um die
größte stadt der welt herum sie
rezitieren mantras drehen gebetsmühlen
beten
[Applaus]
norbu ist wie die meisten sherpas
gläubiger buddhist
vor einer großen expedition kommt noch
ein opfer dazu
norbu bringt dem lama eine flasche
schnaps darlehens war große opfer als
sinnlos ab aber ein bisschen alkohol
stimmt vielleicht die göttin mio
langsamer
die auf dem everest wohnt gnädig wer
weiß wenn ich das nicht machen dann habe
ich kein gutes gefühl im basecamp wenn
ich genügend beet und opfer bin ich in
frieden mit mir und habe keine angst in
die berge zu gehen
[Musik]
das stärkt meine glauben kann nicht
ahnen was für ein großes unglück in drei
wochen über sein land hereinbrechen wird
aber vielleicht helfen im jahr die
gebete und die göttin schickte ihm einen
schutzengel um das erdbeben unbeschadet
zu überstehen
wer den höchsten berg der welt besteigen
will legt sein schicksal ein stück weit
in die hände der natur der combo eisfall
dieses gefährliche drescher labyrinth
ist das tor zu mount everest
letztes jahr gab es hier eine
fürchterliche katastrophe eine lawine
verschüttet er ihm eisfall 16 sherpas
alle expeditionen auf der südseite des
everest wurden danach abgebrochen
jetzt liegt es an diesen männern eine
neue lawinen sichere route durch den
ausfall zu finden
sie sind spezialisten man nennt sie die
eisfall doktoren einmal mehr ziehen sie
mit leitern los um sie über die
gletscherspalten zulegen
die eisfall doktoren arbeiten für alle
expeditionen gemeinsam angestellt sind
sie von einer umweltorganisation die mit
dem gewinn den everest sauber halten
soll
im eis fall zu arbeiten ist ein harter
job
[Musik]
die zeit ist knapp die expeditionsgruppe
werden bald im basecamp eintreffen
ihr tages märsche vom everest entfernt
ist novo allein unterwegs seine freundin
andrea ist immer noch auf einen tracking
mit einer kundin noble dem dörfchen
tarnow eine witwe besuchen deren mann
letztes jahr im eis voll starb tammo ist
ein kleines sherpa dorf in der region
solo combo die bewohner pflanzen
kartoffeln und leben vom tourismus wie
auch expeditionen der witwe gehört dies
ist kleine restaurant
ich kannte den mann der verstarb sehr
gut
ich sage oft im lager 2 er offerierte
uns im at er war ein guter mann und sein
sohn ist ein guter freund von mir
wir waren oft zusammen auf expedition
mit halfen uns stets diese familie ist
mir sehr wichtig
norbu begrüßt an ricoh die witwe des
verstorbenen sherpas
sie führt ihn in die kleine küche ihres
gasthofes hier kocht sie für ihre
kundschaft die trekking touristen wie
kommt sie mit dem verlust ihres mannes
zu recht wenn ich arbeiten gehe denke
ich immer an ihn ich sehe steht sein
gesicht vor meinen augen was kann ich
machen
wie kann ich mein leid loswerden du
sollst nicht schwach sein schwester wenn
du schwäche zeigt ist es auch für seine
töchter spielen
ich bin über mein eigenes leben besorgt
wie soll ich ohne meinen mann leben
ich bin in einer traurigen lage
dabei hatten die beiden für das alter so
schöne pläne mit diesem gasthaus
wir wollten mit diesem gasthaus unseren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten nachdem ein
mann den job am berg aufgegeben haben
würde
dazu bauten wir dieses haus aber mein
mann hielt es nicht zu hause aus er ließ
mich allein zurück wie soll ich jetzt
leben
ich kann nicht von meinen kindern
verlangen bei mir zu bleiben
sie haben ihr eigenes leben sie haben
auch ihre eigene familie
ach ich bin eine alte frau vielleicht
lebe ich noch fünf sechs jahre
meine zeit ist abgelaufen
meine zukunft unsicher finanziell wurde
die witwe gut entschädigt für eine
politische verhältnisse
sie erhielt 15.000 us dollar von der
regierung
und 3000 dollar von der expedition firma
aber das ist ihre ganze altersvorsorge
und der verlust ihres mannes ist nicht
mit geld zu ersetzen
novo kann sich in das leid der witwe
einfügen
auch für ihn wäre der verlust seiner
partnerin andrea schrecklich ohne sie
fühle ich mich nur wie ein halber mensch
sie gibt mir kraft und energie das beste
sie bringt mich dazu ein guter mensch zu
sein bald wird norbu seine andrea wieder
treffen
[Musik]
im gefährlichen gletscherabbruch
arbeiten sich die eisfall doktoren den
berg hoch ein besonders wagemutiger geht
voraus lose gesichert von seinen
kollegen jeden moment kann er einbrechen
denn unter dem schnee liegen gewaltige
gletscherspalten die oft 30 und mehr
meter tief sind
eisfall doktoren verdienen zwischen 2000
und 4000 dollar
das ist weniger als die climbing sherpas
der expeditionen doch für nepal sehr
viel geld aber auch das risiko ist
entsprechend hoch
letztes jahr fiel in eine
gletscherspalte 30 metern ab aber
infolge der schwierigen wirtschaftslage
muss sich diesen job machen auch wenn er
nicht meinen wünschen entspricht
ich muss geld für meiner familie
verdienen um die täglichen ausgaben zu
decken geld ist für mich sehr wichtig
das ist nahe chiba sagt das zentrum des
sherpa landes eine art zermatt im
everest gebiet die sherpas ausnahme
haben es nicht mehr nötig auf die berge
zu klettern
sie führen geschäfte und restaurants
verdienen harte devisen
von angi ausgeht niveau hoch richtung
everest gold belegt dass ich auf einem
der größten touristenpfade nepals man
nennt ihn den kahler bad nauheim benannt
nach dem aussichtspunkt auf den everest
alle trecker wollen einen blick auf den
höchsten berg der welt ergattern
hunderte sind unterwegs scheinbar eine
ganz normale saison am everest zwei
wochen vor dem erdbeben
[Musik]
oben am fuß des everest treffen
unterdessen karawanen von jaxx 1
sie bringen tonnenweise material in
space camp 42 expeditionen mit etwa 1500
personen werden dieses jahr erwartet mit
dem material machen sich die
expeditionen daran ihre zeltlager auf
dem home blitzer aufzustellen
hier errichten die sherpas von himmel an
experience ihr kennt jeder expedition
firma mit der längsten tradition am
everest
geschäftsführer ist der neuseeländer die
sherpas dieser expedition bilden eine
verschworene gemeinschaft 18 von ihnen
stammen aus dem gleichen dorf namen
sports
die meisten schärfer sind jung und stark
man kann diesen harten job auch nur eine
begrenzte zeit ausüben eine kurze
verschnaufpause dann geht die arbeit
weiter
diese expedition gilt als modell für
viele andere
sie bietet einen luxus den man hier kaum
erwarten würde
mopo zeigt ab und verlässt den strom der
trekking touristen
er strebt nach porz dem kleinen sherpa
dorf im schatten der armada plan dem
matterhorn nepals
[Musik]
trotzdem liegt auf einer wunderschönen
terrasse norbu wird in diesem
verschlafenen bergdorf seine freundin
andrea treffen
zwar gibt es hier einige gasthöfe für
trekking touristen aber das dorf wirkt
wie ausgestorben
fast nur frauen alte männer und kinder
sind hier kein wunder denn nicht weniger
als 65 männer aus porz arbeiten am
everest
dort verdienen sie für hiesige
verhältnisse eine stange geld
sie haben keine andere bereit das große
geld verdient wenn man anderswo arbeiten
will braucht es eine ausbildung
qualifikationen und so weiter aber um am
everest arbeiten zu können braucht es
nichts man muss nur die höhe getragen
und stark seinem berg wir haben das in
ihren genen
es ist die beste möglichkeit für sehr
gutes geld zu verdienen
auf seinem streifzug durch port said
trifft norbu eine junge frau sie ist im
zweiten monat schwanger
ihr mann ist einer jener 18 sherpas die
für russell price arbeiten
nach dem letztjährigen unfall am everest
ist es nicht schwierig für dich wenn du
ein mandat oben ist ja ich finde es hart
und schwierig bist du traurig ja
manchmal außer expeditionen gibt es hier
wohl nicht viel arbeit um geld zu
verdienen
vielleicht noch kleine trackings ja nur
kleine trackings man muss bei den
expeditionen arbeiten oder nicht ja er
ist besorgt ein bisschen
norbu verabschiedet sich er hat wenig
erfahren über die wahren gefühle der
frisch verheirateten frau aber das
gehört zur kultur dieser ländlichen
gegend man fügt sich dem schicksal
ich habe viele stationen dieses
geschäfts erleben ich arbeitete als
küchenjunge als bürokraft als klettern
der sherpa und als
dabei sei es gibt keine zukunft auf
diesem weg ich möchte nicht enden wie
viele meiner freunde die sich mit rund
40 oder 45 jahren in einer schlechten
situation befinden
deshalb gründete ich ein eigenes
geschäft um einen schritt weiterzukommen
business ein erfreulicher moment für
norbu seine große liebe und
geschäftspartnerin andrea trifft jeden
moment ein
[Musik]
wie geht es dir sehr gut
dann bist du aufgebrochen um 8 um
viertel vor neun
jetzt bin ich hier und habe auch
frisches brot mitgebracht bist du
wirklich
die beiden gehen den traum vom everest
nun gemeinsam weiter ein wichtiger
schritt ihrer reise ein besuch bei lama
yeshe alle die auf den everest wollen
gehen bei diesem lama in kambodscha
vorbei um seinen segen zu empfangen
verliert sie ein mantra dass dem
bodyguard war des mitgefühls gewidmet
ist dann aber richtet der lama eine sehr
direkte frage an andrea wieso willst du
den everest besteigen
der everest fasziniert mich er ist das
dach der welt und auch aus spiritueller
sicht der faszinierendste aller berge
[Musik]
viele leute kommen und islamische kann
nicht verstehen warum alle auf diesen
berg wollen man kann so viel besseres
tun als auf den bus zu steigen
ich kann den menschen helfen und gutes
tun
er sagt wenn du etwas gutes für die
leute oder die menschheit tust ist das
viel besser als auf den bus zu klettern
prophetische worte von lama yeshe die
audienz von andrea und norbert ist zu
ende jetzt kommen die vielen indischen
bergsteiger dran die warten da magisches
segnet alle jeder bringt ihm etwas bares
mit versteckt in der charta dem
traditionellen begrüßung schal auch bei
la magische läuft das geschäft mit dem
everest sagte mir ich soll andrea dieses
material ihren jeden tag lehre sie dass
man trat ein ist das ist deine
verantwortung
das ist wichtiger als sie auf den
everest sie soll es jeden tag ist
einfach gut dass wir was heute gesagt
wird ist das sehr gut ab und zu auch mal
wieder damit konfrontiert sah und wie
darf da sie darf
noch lebt der gemeinsame traum vom
everest in der nächsten folge erreichte
die beides basislager täter erfahren
viel drüber wir moderne expeditionen gut
funktioniert solche zelte sind die
zukunft aber dann kommt alles ganz
anders
am 25 april erschüttere des schweizers
die leute schrien und rannten
durcheinander
das land liegt römer aber den orden und
andrea reagieren sie verteilen
hilfsgüter die obdachlose sie tut so ist
der magische verlangt hat fortsetzung
folgt in einer woche